since it's design week we have a vff
joining us who has a design dilemma and
she needs help with so please welcome
the lovely robin
hi
ben hi erin
[Applause]
robin um tell us what your design
dilemma is first of all oh through i
have a bookcase that is beautiful it's
natural wood but look at it it is so
boring i don't know
how to decorate this bookcase i have a
few books i have a few knickknacks it's
tucked away in my spare bedroom i want
to make this a centerpiece
a prominent statement piece and how can
i do this
um
i totally see what you're talking about
it like it wants that joy factor it
wants that love it wants that touch ben
and aaron
have an amazing idea i'm gonna turn it
over to them walk us through your diy
vinyl record bookshelves they're so cool
so for music fans this one is especially
fun these are very very scratched albums
we found at a thrift store okay no
vinyls were harmed in the making of this
book
end cap they're they're going to go hard
i've been thinking like with with
bookends is
like we have like bricks from houses
that we've lived in and some dogs that
[Music]
you can make more personal bookends and
then that gives you another object on
your shelf just like something to tell
people about conversation piece and uh
it's super super simple so this is what
we're gonna make yeah okay
this is how you do it
all right you've gotta have very hot
water
so we have a percolation
i'll do the pouring
okay you pour it on the record slowly
and you start to put it down in the
water
you let it bend
it's going to start to melt the vinyl
then
you use something like a cutting board
if you have it
and you can
bend it so you're going to take it there
see it's bendy
and put it under the cutting board
and then you're going to press it
forward
and now that's good only takes a second
yeah you pull that away
that is so cool i was under full
hypnosis the entire time that was
hypnotic to watch yeah
now drew you have a tip
i do um i'm so excited to be
collaborating with ben and aaron napier
i'm having a pinch me moment okay
so i think about
a bookshelf books it's an obvious fit
but is there something different that
you can do with the books themselves so
i'm going to show you an easy way to
transform a book now i'm just taking
scraps of fabric here we're putting tape
on the end they're pre-cut they have a
little bit of an angle
and almost think of it as like a
wrapping job is that you kind of want to
cut
according to the size of the gift you're
wrapping and you want to pull it kind of
taut
and then you want to go to the other
side flip the pages of the book because
you want to do this all on the edges
and i'm going to show you an example
of a bookshelf that i did
in my entryway i found a magazine cover
um that i was really inspired by and i
sort of did my own interpretation
those books were my old antique books
and i painted them
so you can also paint your books if that
really speaks to you or cover it in
fabric okay so this is basically what
it's going to end up looking like and i
kind of thought maybe for you to go with
the records so that the beautiful book
ends that ben and aaron made could
really stand out and not have different
colors
fonts
and type treatment fighting it this way
the beautiful vinyl bookends stick out
and
just a little greenery and flowers and
a way to really let those vinyl bookends
shine and not distract away from them
i don't know robin what do you think are
you
it's amazing i'm a music lover oh i'm an
art lover i'm a reader and everything is
affordable i can do it myself so that's
awesome yeah robin i just want to thank
you so much for trusting us with your
delight design dilemma and um ben and
aaron it has been such an honor to have
you here on this show
um and i'm really excited about the new
show that's coming um it's in watemka
alabama is that correct and it'll be
coming hopefully around this spring
yeah
we
did over an entire town yep it's 12 huge
projects six episodes it's a mini series
it'll be
different from hometown in a lot of ways
and then it's going to have all the
heart all the design that people love
and yeah it's some of the most
incredible
people that we have ever met
um that we get to work with on these
houses so deserving people get beautiful
things yeah it was really cool and then
i have a new show that's on discovery
plus
called hometown ben's workshop and i'm
thinking that drew needs to come i think
so too
do i start running now or do i wait for
the call i'm really excited i would i'll
be there in a heartbeat are you kidding
yes just come this way well
okay i'm ready you just say when and
i'll
i'll be right there and i can't wait for
hometown takeover
um which will be coming to hgtv this
spring and hometown
sundays on hgtv um there's hometown
ben's workshop which is available to
stream now on discovery plus hopefully
i'll be getting to go there soon and
speaking of takeover you've taken over
the world and you've taken over our
hearts i can't thank you enough for
being here today
this is so fun thank you tell your
little girl i said hello by the way
oh you know what i take it back tell her
gertie said hello
thank you so much i would love to see
you guys soon
[Music]
you